because we can see Boris Johnson as is
to scientific a medical device for this
latest down history press conference
first of all I want to update you on the
latest data in our fight against corona
virus I can report through the
government's ongoing testing and
monitoring program that as of today 1
million nine hundred and twenty one
thousand seven hundred and seventy tests
for corona virus have now been carried
out in the UK including one hundred
thousand four hundred and ninety tests
carried out yesterday two hundred and
twenty three thousand and sixty people
have tested positive that's an increase
of three thousand eight hundred and
seventy seven cases since yesterday
eleven thousand four hundred and one
people are currently in hospital with
corona virus down from eleven thousand
seven hundred and sixty eight the
previous day and sadly of those tested
positive for corona virus across all
settings thirty two thousand and sixteen
oh I'd that's an increase of two hundred
and ten fatalities since yesterday this
figure includes deaths in all settings
not just in hospitals before we begin
questions from the public and from the
media I just want to remind people of a
number of important things I said in my
address to the nation last night and can
we have the first slide please first in
order to monitor our progress we are
establishing a new co vid alert level
system the co vid alert level has five
levels each relating to the level of
threat posed by the virus the level will
be primarily determined by the R value
and the number of corona virus cases in
turn that Co vid alert level
we'll determine the level of social
distancing measures in place and the
lower the level the fewer the measures
the higher the level the stricter the
measures throughout the period of
lockdown which started on March the 23rd
we've been at level four meaning a kovat
nineteen epidemic is in general
circulation and transmission is high or
rising exponentially thanks to the hard
work sacrifices of the British people in
this lockdown we've helped to bring the
our level down a number of infections
down and we're now in a position to
begin moving to level three in steps
next slide please
and we set out the first three steps we
will take carefully to modify the
measures gradually ease the lockdown and
begin to allow people to return to their
way of life but crucially while avoiding
what would be a disastrous second peak
that overwhelms the NHS after each step
we will closely monitor the impact of
that step on the are and the number of
infections and all the available data
and we'll only take the next step when
we are satisfied that it is safe to do
so so step one from this week those who
cannot work from home should now speak
to their employer about going back to
work you can now spend time outdoors and
exercise as often as you like you can
meet one person outside of your
household outside outdoors provided you
stay two metres apart the social
distancing measures remain absolutely
crucial to us keeping the infection rate
and the number of K
is down as low as we possibly can so
step 2
from June the 1st the earliest we aim as
long as the data allows it we aim for
primary schools to reopen for some
pupils in smaller class sizes
non-essential retail to start to reopen
when and where it's safe to do so
cultural and sporting events to take
place behind closed doors without crowds
and then step 3 no later than July the
4th and again only if the data says it
is safe we aim to allow more businesses
and premises to open including
potentially those offering a personal
care such as leisure facilities public
places and and places of worship many of
these businesses will need to operate in
new ways to ensure they're safe and we
will work with these sectors on how to
do this so given we've taken the first
step in carefully adjusting some of the
measures today and therefore our advice
to people what to do we've also updated
our messaging we're now asking people to
stay alert control the virus and save
lives and yes staying alert for the vast
majority of people still means staying
at home as much as possible but there
are a range of other actions we're
advising people to take as we modify our
measures people should stay alert by
working from home if you can limiting
contact with other people keeping
distance if you go out 2 meters apart
where possible washing your hands
regularly wearing a face covering when
you're in an enclosed spaces and where
it's difficult to be socially distant
for example in some shops or on public
transport
and if you or anyone in your household
has symptoms repeat you all need to self
isolate because if everyone stays alert
and follows the rules we can control
coronavirus by keeping the Arden and
reducing the number of infections and
this is how we can continue to save
lives and livelihoods as we begin as a
nation to recover from coronavirus